mr. hukum thanks very much indeed for
your time we heard it there we're still
not really clear what happened so
perhaps you can tell us what happened
yesterday well what happened was we
called an MEP meeting for you keep em
ep's to discuss with steam wolf reports
in media and press that he was in talks
with the Tory party and you know you
have to understand that we've just lost
a leader that would been in place 18
days so as emic Paige was quite
concerned that the next leader
however he/she may be he's going to
second shorter 2020 in going to be a
steady hand so legitimate questions to
save Wolf's
whole instigated these meetings was it
you or was it the Tory party but it
obviously Stephen wolf
it obviously escalated quite quickly
didn't it mr. hook and we've hearing
from the Daily Mail quote today from mr.
wolf himself Mike came at me landed a
blow the doorframe took the biggest hit
after I was shoved into it and I knew
I'd taken a whack and was pretty shaken
so did you punch mr. wolf well he fell
in his story up then right uh if you
want the truth I'll tell you the truth
mr. wolf explained to the to the meeting
he's part in the last leadership
election where he's D stated that his
paperwork had gone in and he had
evidence of it but it hadn't been
accepted I then said no Stephen you have
20 days to get this in the reason it
never went said it was your fault
whereas mr. wolf then stood up in front
of the meeting in front of witnesses and
said right if it's going to be this turn
of the of the meeting lets me and you
take this outside
mano a mano and that was his words man
no ill manner he made for a small
anteroom taking his jacket off I entered
that room and he approached me he came
at me
there was no a nice Ana to strongly get
this across there was not Pontius Tron
there was no blaster on there was no
slap versus there was no pushing
there was a tussle between so well an
elderly grandfather and a 40 year old
MEP quite silly quite embarrassing
handbag at dawn girl-on-girl it was it
was embarrassing it lasted seconds
whereas the door opened mr. wolf fell
back into the pinch of the inch of the
rope until a male ma pee
his head never it's any glass any metal
any chair or anything since I never
punched Stephen walls so mr. wolf is
lying when he says that you landed a
blow I haven't spoke to mr. wolf I've
read any pressure on media on this other
than what I've seen early this morning
what I am saying now is the truth is
what I'm saying
is no blood either from me or him what's
wrong okay I'm sure we will find out
more because there is gonna be an
investigation but the wider context of
all of this is that in the papers today
we've seen quotes from people who have
been within the party sources ended in
the party and from outside the party
saying that this is an aggressive party
Leanne wood last night said it's a party
full of thugs you've been described in
the Daily Mail today as someone you
would have good reason to leave you kit
because of enjoin'd the Tories because
he was that aggressive if you cross him
you'd better watch out are you a violent
man and as you kept a violent party mr.
hooker I'm quite sure that the media has
gone right through my yet through my
history the party's done that there is
no record whatsoever of any violence we
are we as ma Pease as as politicians
have hated debates we stand our ground
this unfortunately got out of hand
I never instigated this this this this
you know this incident it wasn't me
mr. wolf in instigated it's not me and
as I said and I say again I never throw
a punch
it doesn't do many favours to either
view of Britain and specifically you
kept in terms of Europe we voted to
leave the EU and there we are in
corridors in Strasbourg having scuffles
altercations this is an absolute
embarrassment to both Britain and your
party isn't it it's an embarrassment to
me it's an embarrassment to Stephen it
should not have happened as I say it was
a heated debate that got out of hand
that Stephen wants you to suck a little
bit further it wasn't me that instigated
this and what should happen now if you
say it's been a scuffle you're saying
that mr. wolf has lied that you didn't
land a blow should you both CSIS be
suspended should should he be suspended
for coming at you and an investigation
as I believe will be taking place next
week one of which I am quite set open
and play stood to participate in and the
both shadows terribly put forward
Stephen has emailed me this morning
Cheney regrets the situation and wants
to mate and shake hands I've emailed him
back and said yes I'm ok with that I
will meet up with Sheikh and and
hopefully we'll forget all about it mr.
mr. hukum thank you very much indeed for
your time live in Leeds this afternoon
we appreciate you speaking to us thank
you thank you thank you